à 47 ans monde ça fait chefs
d'entreprise comme tous les jours cet
informaticien d'origine tunisienne
seront à son bureau
en région parisienne la gueule du monde
mon associé le monde ça faisait
longtemps défini comme musulman non
pratiquant
mais depuis quelques semaines il ne
consomme plus d'alcool s'est mise à la
prière observent le ramadan et a même
décidé de se rendre à la mecque avec
femme et enfants à l'origine de cette
transformation qui a surpris jusqu'à son
épouse sonia pourtant pratiquante un
besoin nouveau de spiritualité conjuguée
à un événement intervenu il y a deux
mois un événement lié à son film ryan
quatre ans qui présentent des signes
d'autisme
depuis l'âge de 2 ans élu pour ça que
j'aime a d'abord pyjama d'abord aller
bébé je pensais monfils est pour quelque
chose
effectivement je pense dans la vie je
crois pas beaucoup au hasard des choses
qui se passent subtilement et puis le
fait d'avoir à yenne avec le problème
qu'il a ça nous a vraiment n'ont pas
ouvert les yeux ouverts le coeur même je
peux vous avouer que la démarche outil
aussi était suite à un rêve que j'ai eus
donc grève où j'ai rêvé que le coran
j'ai vu le coran dans mon rêve
d'après les connaisseurs en super league
les gens pouvaient le coran dans leurs
rêves c'est des gens béni je remercie le
bon dieu c'est super mais je pense qu'il
ya une bonne étoile quelque part qui
veille sur moi sur ma faim
hélas activement comme brian me
préoccuper beaucoup effectivement je pu
rien dont le rêve est considéré hier on
m'a demandé d'aller allait donner un
réel de l'eau 2ème de la mecque
donc du coup ça m'a travaillé d'aller
puis je commençais à m'intéresser
je suis trouvé dans un état assez
spirituel et jamais j'avais vraiment
envie de faire ça à porter ça la famille
a décidé de boucler son périple
religieux en une semaine
au programme petit pèlerinage à la
mecque est visible de médine deuxième
ville sainte de l'islam
à la veille du grand départ la famille
se concentre sur les derniers petits
détails pratiques
ça c'est le sait ce que porteront tous
les hommes donc sans vêtement donc même
sans sous vêtements je dirais un jeu ça
et puis l'autre sur sa cousine et puis
d'autre part dire tout ça je le sais pas
comment ça se passe mais on va trouver
un moyen de le mettre
je n'ai pas fumé un petit peu parce
qu'ils disent et c'est pas mal de
parfumer la femme ça sent bon pour sonia
c'est a priori plus simple
quoique j'espère qu'elle n'est pas
transparent et c'est transparent c'est
par là tu resteras des problèmes la
police militaire la police
quant à inès cinq ans elle semble avoir
déjà tout compris voile ma fille tu sais
papa ne t'oblige pas tout volé ma chérie
surtout pas la maison lemaitre à la
mecque uniquement chéri après c'est
parti
direction beyrouth première étape
com
oh
une heures d'escale au liban sonia les
enfants ont tout juste le temps
d'enfiler leurs nouveaux vêtements
monde sauf en profite pour faire sa
prière puis tout le monde se précipite
dans l'avion pour l'arabie saoudite
plus qu'une heure de vol moncef se lance
dans des incantations sonia lit le coran
m
c'est le moment de revêtir le pagne
symbole de pureté et d'humilité du
croyant face à la grandeur du tout
puissant le couple peut désormais
proclamé son intention d'effectuer le
petit pèlerinage mais il faut veiller à
prononcer l'invocation rituel au bon
moment avant le début du survol de la
zone sainte
là maintenant je vais vraiment faire le
apparemment faire l'attention de l'arbre
elle m'a dit avoir rencontré non non
c'est pas dans le rapport la 105 réserve
ce moment la ramène
vous abandonne 1 22 minutes dire
en 22 minutes
donc j'attends c'est facile à bec à
leurs membres
non une fois on verra après ce label
calamars et payent les chérit le pays
on répète
voilà
latvala
ah c'est vrai ça me
ça me change un peu
tout à l'heure en servette
on va essayer maintenant
ryan je sais pour concentrer pour
pas besoin d'être aspect actuel
mais je pensais souvent
déjà
sans léger
c'est finalement le commandant de bord
qui met tout le monde d'accord
nous sommes au dessus du périmètre sacré
qui s'étend de la mecque à médine
le petit pèlerinage de la omra commence
ici entre ciel et terre aéroports de
djeddah 22 heures 30 et 35 degrés sous
les néons
la fatigue commence à se faire sentir
mais pas question de faire une pause
toubon pèlerins se doit absolument de se
rendre au plus vite à la mecque dans le
saint des saints
il reste encore 80 kilomètres à
parcourir et sonia n'est plus tout à
fait certaine d'avoir prononcé son
invocation au bon moment je ne sais pas
si je les dis au bon moment
j'ai dit à van
non membre
c'est à voir
ma
ça se rattrapera
pas en payant
en forme des grands jours en comptant
sans équivalent
la nécessité
la mecque la mer décidés
a checkpoint filtre soigneusement
l'entrée de la ville strictement
interdite à tout non musulmans
l'interdît qui frappe la ville a
alimenté bien des fantasmes
au premier abord la mecque apparaît
pourtant sous les traits de n'importe
quelle petite ville du monde arabe en
proie à la frénésie des nuits du ramadan
je
n'attendez pas sincèrement à trouver une
ville comme ça vous êtes surpris par la
ville avant la suppression des surprises
dans cet énorme
je m'attendais un désert auto puis
endroit petit peu on va attendre d'y
voir commencer
j'imaginais ça va comme un geste une
mosquée on voit là une mosquée à la
mecque et puis c'est tout
adaptation au jeu souffre pas d'être
vraiment
vous êtes surpris de voir c'est une
ville traces qui bourdonnent et brodeur
à minuit effectivement
hôtel non arrivée à l'hôtel conformément
au rituel
sonia et moncef vont se rendre dès ce
soir à la grande mosquée le couple
souhaite vivre son premier moment de
dévotion en dehors de notre présence
holmes
muni d'une caméra discrète nous décidons
d'aller nous perdre dans les ruelles de
la ville
les deux heures du matin les abords de
la grande mosquée grouille de monde
malgré sa taille le lieu le plus visité
de l'islam ne parvient pas à contenir
tous les fidèles alors qu'on s'installe
montpon
en cette fin de ramadan période
d'intense ferveur religieuse
la capitale spirituelle de l'islam
attire les croyants des quatre coins de
la planète
la mecque et son million d'habitants
s'apprête à accueillir l'un des plus
imposants rassemblement de l'année
l'avant-garde des invités de dieu est
déjà sur place
indifférente au tumulte ambiant ici on
vient d'abord pour prier partout 7 jours
sur 7
de jour comme de nuit
deuxième jour cette fois à remettre
l'homme au keffieh rouge et de la partie
les autorités nous impose la présence de
ce représentant du ministère de
l'information
les consignes de l'officiel tiennent en
une phrase il est strictement interdit
de filmer en dehors de sa présence à la
mecque
les caméras sont à peine tolérés la
police religieuse une puissante milice
chargée de traquer tous comportements
déviants interdit même aux pèlerins de
prendre des photos sonia rendez vous
avec son mari sur le parvis de la
mosquée moncef a décidé de bénir ryan
dans l'eau 2 mm
l'eau sacrée qui coule de tous les
robinets du synthé dix fils selon la
tradition lot 2 mm a des vertus
miraculeuses
au moment où nous nous apprêtons à
descendre l'escalier un religieux surgit
de la foule est un brutalement la caméra
ce jour-là nous frôlons l'arrêt
définitif du tournage
m
g
et
et pour nourrir
karzaï
troisième soir veille du 27e jour du
ramadhan c'est la nuit du destin
celle qui célèbrent l'anniversaire de la
révélation du coran au prophète
ce soir ils sont près de 3 millions à
être du rendez vous autant que pour le
grand pèlerinage qui se tient une fois
par an
monde sain fait sonia ont choisi cette
nuit unique pour effectuer leur omra
familiale exceptionnellement les
autorités nous ouvre les portes de la
régie télé de la mosquée et nous
autorise même à mobiliser les 23 caméras
du site pour tenter de retrouver nos
pèlerins
après 45 minutes de recherche nous
parvenons enfin à localiser
ryan sur les épaules demande c'est nous
avons de la chance
notre famille n'a pas encore commencé le
parcours rituel
moncef et les siens vont tout d'abord
faire cette fois le tour de la kaaba
pour saluer ce cube qui symbolise le
dieu unique
c'est difficile ryan commence à montrer
des signes d'agitation mais moncef sait
qu'il ne peut plus rebrousser chemin
la marée blanche des pèlerins n'autorise
aucun arrêt une fois pris dans la vague
mieux vaut se laisser porter par le
courant
monde sauf les siens sont emportés par
une foule de 300 mille personnes fin du
premier tour il en reste six autres
niché dans un angle du temple protégé
par un écrin d'argent la pierre noire
seul objet que l'islam permet de générer
ce soir monde ça fait sonia ne
parviendront pas à s'approcher de ce
fragment de météorite que la tradition
présente comme étant à l'origine du
monde
il ya trop de monde et les militaires
veulent prévenir tout risque de
débordements
chaque année plusieurs dizaines de
pèlerins trouvent la mort au pied de la
maison de dieu
terrassé par la chaleur l'émotion et
parfois même le torrent des croyants au
bout d'une heure nos pèlerins
parviennent à s'extraire du tourbillon
des fidèles
direction le saillie à couloirs de 400
mètres logé dans une aile de la grande
mosquée notre famille doit parcourir le
trajet à sept reprises
marcher dans les pas de bagarre les
pouces d'abraham c'est ici qu aurait
jailli la source 2 mm qui lui permit
d'abreuver son fils ismaël
le petit pèlerinage s'achève à l'issue
de ce cheminement de près de 3 km 2h de
rituels et encore deux heures pour
gagner l'hôtel moncef a réalisé son rêve
en effet les sept tours de la mecque
cegid j'essaie je me disais maintenant
c'est le moment de
se relâcher de effectivement j'ai réussi
quelques quelques moments mais pas j'ai
pas déconnecter mais certainement mes
enfants étaient étaient avec moi parce
que ryan physiquement rester là c'est un
moment de bonheur moi et lui je
considère comme un copain parce qu'il
est toujours quand vous voyez les
toujours ses mains sur les genoux à
l'honneur sur et où ça faisait mal et
moi je l'aimais beaucoup ça disait que
je l'aimé et puis j'aurai pour lui et
puis je me suis finalement je suis là
parce que vous imaginez que depuis com a
décidé de faire ce voyage d'à
j'attendais ce moment est réellement est
venue passer c'est donc pas l'écrire
mais si la joie c'est ses immenses et
c'est tout tout tout tout musulman rêve
de ce moment-là de devoir je dirais la
nec
c'est en la en la vie de près c'est très
visible
j'avais les
les bibles je souhaitais je le sentais
emporté par un sentiment je sais pas
et comme si j'étais entre dieu et moi
vraiment je ne ressentais pas les gens
qui nous ya dans cette cité c'est le
sentiment très fort vraiment c'est on
est en a des yeux quoi c'est à dire on
est venu on a tout eu envie de faire de
se donner deux êtres d'être un musulman
ancien héros tout le monde souhaite
converger parce que c'est la m c'est
clair c'est tellement on à l'essai
ce attendait un petit peu assez
bousculade à la fin j'ai eu peur pour la
vie de me sens français serment
la petite est étonnant c'est le respect
a vu ryan temps mais de par terre je
vais ramasser patiemment la fin je prie
le
c'est mûr pour arriver à l'hôtel ça
c'est très très peur eu la peur de ma
vie on a passé de bousculades
donc quand même les gens sont gentils
ils ne peuvent rien imaginé trois
millions de personnes
troisième et dernier jour de notre
séjour à la mecque tout juste remis de
leurs émotions de la veille monde s'est
fait sonia veulent se rendre dans un
souk populaire achmed l'omniprésent
représentants des autorités nous impose
la visite du centre commercial le plus
rutilant de la mecque
le royaume saoudien tient à exhiber ses
signes extérieurs de modernité direction
la librairie monde ça pouvait acheter un
souvenir ce sera un coran
ça de la main de la mecque cédait
symboliquement c'est pour les gens
instrument qu'on se retrouvait sa
à paris ce problème
c'est le souk c'est moderne c'est
incroyable
le temps s'avance achète savoir
ça
il n'y a pas eu un seul magasin qui est
vide
pas le temps de flâner armen nous
convient un mystérieux rendez vous
l'invitation est poli mais pressante
nous décidons de le suivre
dix minutes plus tard
nous débarquons dans cette pièce aux
décors aussi kitsch que flamboyant
contrairement aux apparences nous ne
sommes pas dans la demeure d'un prince
mais au siège d'une association
caritative qui a pignon sur rue
l'accueil est chaleureux et courtois à
la hauteur du sens légendaire de
l'hospitalité arabe
le cheikh mansour un notable de la
mecque
il nous dévoile le contenu des cartons
repas que son organisation distribuer
pendant le mois du ramadan islam rime
d'abord avec générosité et on tient
visiblement à nous le montrer
esplanade de la grande mosquée cette
fois notre caméra est accepté
l'organisation est sans faille
professionnels le cheikh mansour a pensé
à tous y compris aux traducteurs
repas par jour
j'ignore encore été
un million
combien de personnes en vacances
goal com combien
moncef participent à la distribution
mais au moment de la rupture du jeûne il
est assailli par une forêt de bras
ans
même le très énergique mansour a du mal
à contenir la foule il parvient tout de
même à nous faire immortaliser l'image
de la remise de la date rituel
à
elle
retour à l'hôtel monde ça fait sonia
profite de ce rare moment de détente
pour prier ensemble dans quelques
minutes le couple ira saluer une
dernière fois la kaaba c'est la dernière
soirée à la mecque
l'heure d'un premier bilan
l'essentiel est fait un nom d' essentiel
c'est celle avec c'est les roms la nuit
duel de ma femme et moi même et puis
j'ai des enfants donc je peux dire que
oui c'est un campement 5h30 du matin
nous quittons la cité qui ne dort jamais
à 450 km au nord médine deuxième ville
sainte de l'islam
chassé de la mecque par sa propre tribu
qui refuse de voir en lui le prophète
d'une nouvelle religion mahomet est
accueillie ici en héros en 622 de l'ère
chrétienne
c'est l'hégire exil en arabe qui marque
le début du calendrier musulman
médine abrite la mosquée du prophète la
première de l'histoire de l'islam et
c'est à partir d'ici que les premiers
cavaliers musulmans partent à la
conquête de la mecque avant de se
répandre aux quatre coins du monde pour
porter le message de l'islam
si la mecque scintille médine rayonne
plus vaste plus moderne la ville lumière
un million d'habitants est animée mais
tranquille
seul point commun avec la mecque le flux
incessant des pèlerins et les
inévitables souk moderne commerçants
d'origine diverse propose chapelet tapis
et autres breloques made in china
le tout dans un décor digne des centres
commerciaux américains
auj
17h40
l'appel à la prière la fin de la journée
de jeu pour notre famille c'est l'heure
de goûter au premier véritable repas
depuis le début du voyage
monde ça fait des rentes et mais
toujours aussi enthousiaste se dresse un
peu plus relax que la match as roma pour
l'instant l'hôtel plus européen que
que la moyenne des hôtels à la mer
voilà je vois si
deux autres conférences dansant salle
s'est passé
on va tout
qu'est ce qui vous fait dire ça
on voit par là vous êtes en train de
filmer a pas trop de
à 6 ans il appelle à la mecque quasiment
toutes les semaines vous allez justifier
avoir
responsable du ministère de
l'information s'avère alors là ça semble
être à s'exprimer
22h30 la famille au complet se dirige
vers la mosquée de médine où est enterré
le prophète
contrairement à celle de la mecque
cette mosquée n'est pas mixte les femmes
n'y sont admises que quelques heures par
jour pas de chance ce soir c'est le tour
des hommes et sonia doit rebrousser
chemin avec inès
le dôme le plus célèbre de l'islam
surplombe la pièce qui abrite la
dépouille mortelle de mahomet monde cf
qui ne se sépare jamais de ryan se joint
au cortège discipline et des visiteurs
le messager de l'islam a été enterré à
l'endroit même où il a rendu son dernier
souffle en 632 derrière ses portes en
argent trois corps repose à gauche celui
du prophète
à droite ce d'abou bakr et d'omar les
deux premiers califes les premiers
successeurs de mahomet les saoudiens ont
conçu le parcours de façon à éviter tout
élan idolâtre courtoise mais intraitable
les sentinelles veillent surtout à
rappeler aux croyants que le musulman ne
se prosternent que devant son créateur
monde c'est comme les autres saluent et
puis s'éloigne
sixième et dernier jour du voyage monde
ça fait sonia veulent poursuivre sur les
traces du prophète la montagne de rudes
à quelques centaines de mètres de la
ville pourchassés par les mecquois le
prophète et ses troupes y ont subi une
demi-défaite contraints de fuir
baho mais ses deux principaux
lieutenants se sont réfugiés dans une
anfractuosité révélée par le divin
rapporte la tradition musulmane
ça va c'est pas mort tu es un mec comme
ça c'est vrai qu'on est des skalli le
prophète et de ses compagnons aboubakar
et en mars en vue dans cette montagne et
la voilà il fait nuit
et puis le seigneur les arrivées aux
mains du kansas endroit là et là où ils
étaient assises le prophète
la bataille s'est ouvert pour leur
laisser
suivant cette faille là et là ça sera
vraiment très bon le lieu est d'autant
plus visité que la roche il dégage une
odeur de muscles et dambre un phénomène
sujet à toutes les interprétations monde
s'est fait d'émules
sonia elle est bouleversée
hier c'est fort et cela c'est très fort
ces scellés pierre tout dégage une odeur
mais surtout celle ci voici donc la
pierre ou se serait assis le prophète
passant très bon je sais quoi c'est tout
et à quoi qu'on voit à quoi vous pensez
l'accord vous êtes assise c'est
incroyable on fait ce que je me sois la
place du prophète
c'est grandiose il a bien qu'apparemment
il s'est passé il a et il a laissé cette
odeur cogir de vraiment sort santander a
lui fait
c'est magique c'est fantastique tout ça
ça serait perdant que les gens
comprennent sa juste valeur
comprennent que la religion toutes
religions n'ont pas tous que les destins
prix quand même
se trouve exposé à tort je pense qu'on
dit de choses à l'islam aux musulmans
vraiment c'est pas juste ce n'est pas
juste parce que c'est pas ça j'ai pas vu
un seul d un commentaire politique ou de
haine envers qui que ce soit la ce a
chassé des gens pris pour dieu
on se rapproche de dieu et ça le vrai
islam l'islam c'est la continuité du
judaïsme du christianisme c'est écrit
c'est un message pour en trois tomes je
serai l'islam ce troisième temps pour
tout
en une semaine notre couple a fait le
plein de spiritualité dans quelques
heures
moncef retrouvera son entreprise et ses
80 salariés
pour lui rien ne changera vraiment il
est juste devenue pratiquants
et